[Music]
it's a hundred and two degrees a pretty
normal Dubai summer evening my brother
and I we see the Golden Navy Chevy Tahoe
parked around the corner even though we
had just finished soccer practice we
make a dash for the AC we know is
waiting for us as we get closer we see
our mom in the driver's seat and our two
cousins in the car waiting for us we
haven't seen them in a couple years so
as soon as we hop in there are those
enthusiastic hellos that you know
teenagers are famous for hey what's up
not much cool
so our mom asks how was soccer practice
good but I'm really tired yeah I know
I have no idea how Cameron is so fit I
noticed our cousin's giving us weird
looks yeah seriously he's the most fit
guy on the team and I've been training
all summer weird right
well my cousins are British and if you
know anything about their lingo my
brother and I had just been describing
how attractive our teammate Cameron was
the same words mean different things to
different people and it doesn't stop
there you'd hear all sorts of
interesting things at an international
High School in Dubai for example talks
about who had the highest quality phone
would get weird looks from our Korean
classmates to them quality meant brand
new or why my Japanese classmates would
start laughing to them quality meant
zero defect the same words mean
different things to different people but
let's be real
calling your teammate hot by accident or
describing your Nokia 3310 as a zero
defect phone
that's kind of funny well sometimes the
different meanings of words aren't so
funny sometimes they lead to distance
between friends distance in our
communities distance in our society and
surprisingly one of these words is
dialogue so some of you are looking at
me the same way my cousin's did that day
and I can't blame you for many in this
room the following definition of
dialogue found in an essay titled the
power of dialogue will resonate it's
defined it as as a discussion aimed at
fostering mutual insights and common
purpose
sounds like a great definition right
well there's an increasing body of
research done by experts like Jacob Hess
that focus on the negative connotations
conservatives hold of this world of this
word it's actually pretty interesting
many people are concerned with the lack
of conservative representation by some
estimates 90% of those involved with the
concept either through funding it
developing it or advocating for it or
liberal so why do I care
well these types of conversation have
been a fabric of my family growing up I
had four grandparents that were all
teachers both my parents have lived all
around the world I have two younger
brothers were 15 months apart and I
really hate to admit this right now
but not only are they taller than me
they're also smarter the youngest is
getting his PhD PhD in Geoscience and
the middle one made the smartest
decision of us all he decided not to go
to grad school all of this is to say we
don't have the Serio typical
relationship with conversations about
values or the word or the world or
politics for us it's exciting and
expected for us to bring our different
perspectives to the dining room table or
during the holidays so with that kind of
upbringing you can imagine how excited I
was to come to the GSB and have these
types of conversations with some of the
smartest people I've ever met that are
all changed about a year ago when
President Trump announced his
immigration ban I was really excited to
understand what my classmates thought of
the issue so I decided to form some
small discussion groups well
fast-forward a couple weeks to Wednesday
February 22nd I'm in Arbuckle dining
hall
talking with one of my more conservative
friends let's call him Jim we're talking
about current events and eventually we
start talking about the ban Wow Jim I
bet a lot of our classmates would love
to hear that perspective you should join
one of the groups I'm putting together
in a couple weeks
sure sounds good who's gonna be there
what are the details I'll list a couple
people all right so what's the format
how is it gonna be structured oh you
know it's gonna be pretty casual during
the evening over pizza it's just gonna
be a dialogue on the issue he grows
silent I had said something wrong I
don't think that's for me sorry oh
really why I don't know if I want to sit
there and be lectured on my views on the
issue no no no this is going to be a
dialogue you know where we try and
understand you yeah I know what dialogue
is I'll pass thanks I probably shouldn't
have been that surprised earlier that
week I'd sent an email to another
conservative friend with the title
finding the right forum for dialogue he
responded with really appreciate the
efforts to open up discussions but don't
believe this is the right place for me
to help sorry so why was my message so
off even though it's not required many
expect dialog to alter their views on
issues if you are in a room and you are
participating usually it's to mediate
conflict and to do that it's usually
required that you find common ground or
you're looking for solutions or
consensus which all require you to
change your views so if the overwhelming
majority of organizers of dialogue are
liberals most of the time they're
looking for common ground and many times
it's expected that participants will
soften or change their views hopefully
now you start to see why conservatives
view this as the tool liberals used to
bring people to their side so what did I
decide to do about it
I decided to dive into the research and
understand why this term was alienating
some of my friends I had lunch with
Keith Hennessey a former adviser to
George W Bush I took a class with James
Fishkin the director for the center of
deliberative democracy I had multiple
calls with interfaith dialogue expert
Randi Paul
if the same words mean different things
to different people research has shown
that reframing the concept of dialogue
can reinforce the healthy norms of
discourse that are practiced on both
sides so armed with this view of the
issue I was able to successfully host
multiple discussion groups last quarter
with not just those two friends but with
several of our conservative classmates I
did so partly by highlighting the
following three benefits of dialogue and
as you try to engage with others and
similar types of interactions I hope you
can remember to mention them as well
expand your knowledge even if you
believe you possess the objective truth
participating in these types of
conversations a lot allows you to test
out your own beliefs and gain new and
interesting perspectives and information
you otherwise would not have received
advocate effectively those that
participate in dialogue are better
missionaries and advocates if the world
doesn't see an issue the way you would
like or in the right way
participating in this discussion will
help you understand why on your story
dialogue is an excellent platform for
people to become their own platform and
not just defined by others or
organizations like mainstream media the
problem is as we shy away from these
types of conversations we allow certain
that we have sulphate false assumptions
that certain groups speak for an entire
movement or that false assumptions can
continue to persist so for example Isis
does not represent all of Islam and
neither does one conservative movement
represent the entire camp this though is
lost when we aren't the ones talking
about our own personal stories in these
types of conversations so different
meanings of words can lead it can lead
to you some funny stories and sometimes
they can lead to distance while other
times they're the foundation of a
country we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
the phrase all men are created equal
means something different to us today
then it mean meant to our founding
fathers
and that's okay they had different ideas
different assumptions different
connotations but they worked through it
they did so by defining those
differences and the benefits of them
today let's do the same thing let's
realize that dialogue can mean different
things to different people but better
yet let's reframe the concept in a more
inclusive way so we all want to
participate doing so will literally make
us a better country and by the way is it
just me or is the word literally
starting to mean something differently
yes thank you
[Applause]
[Music]